There are some dangers that come with the write-back policy
of the buffer cache, a sudden system rash or power failure
would mean that all the changes made in memory only would
be lost. If the storage device is removal, it could just
be that the user unplugged it before ejecting. It would be
a nice idea if we could periodically copy all the changes
reflected in memory to the disk. Maybe we could do this
when some fixed number of dirty blocks is reached. The trouble
is that the dirty blocks will likely be scattered all
over the disks and we have to spend an inordinate amount
of seek time just putting the right head of the disk
in their correct place. Indeed it's the seek time, that makes
random access to a disk so slow in general. Sequetial
access can be thousands of times faster than random access. It'd
be so much easier if we could just write everything to
one contiguous block. This is the idea behind journalling file systems.
They reserve a contiguous portion of the disk for this
express purpose. We write the changes to the journal quickly,
and mark the dirty box in memory as clean. Then,
at a more opportune time, we apply all these changes stored
in the journal to the appropriate files on the disk.
The name journal comes from the analogy to a diary that
one might write in every day to record the changes
in one's life, in time sequential order. Here we are recording
the changes to the file system. Of course, this does complicate
reading from the disk somewhat. Any time we read from the disk,
we need to check the journal to see if there are any
changes to apply. Total time spent on writing is slower. After all,
we are doing two writes, instead of just one. The key
is, that the write to the journal is faster, and that is
the one we're doing at the critical time when we found that
we found we had too many dirty pages, or blocks, in memory.
Journalling also has the advantage that it helps with crashes.
Problems typically occur when the right to summon important data
structure, like an inode, is interrupted by some system crash
or power failure. Let's consider what happens, when a write
from the journal to the rest of the disk is
interrupted first. Well, in that case, the change that we
need to apply will still be in a journal and
so we can just reapply it on restart. No problem.
The other write to worry about is the write to the
journal itself. A failed write to the journal, however, can be detected
by a checksum. And then the change can simply be ignored,
again, leaving the important data structure on disk in a consistent state.